the bomb ripped through the center of
the Protestant Church in the middle of
Sunday service images too graphic to be
broadcast showed the dead and injured
lying among these pews and chairs
survivors screaming children were among
the victims of what the Army says was an
improvised explosive device
noise coming from the church
any victims among members of the church
unfortunately
we have too many victims of these
attacks in our city of kasindi we are
all affected by this situation and it
has touched our brothers and sisters
it's the latest eruption in years of
violence in the Borderlands between the
DRC and Uganda soldiers from both
countries have been battling fighters
from the Allied Democratic forces or ADF
which in 2019 pledged allegiance to isil
the bomb exploded inside a packed Church
it caused many deaths and injuries it is
clear that this terrorist Act was
carried out by terrorists of the ADF
originally a Ugandan armed group The ADF
has been based inside DRC territory
since the 1990s it's accused of killing
hundreds of villagers in raids over the
last two years Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera